PLAYED THE OUTDOOR GAMES THIS
SEASON.
WE GIVE YOU THE ZAXBY'S'S
OPENING PUCK DROP.
UNDERWAY, THE E UP -- RIGHT HER
GOING TO SEE IF THIS WENT OFF
SOMETHING,SAAD TRIES TO GET LOO
SCORES!  TO THE MIDDLE.
AND HE  BOBBLES RIGHT HERE.
BUT, HE JUST -- IT GOES THROUGH
PAT ON THE PUCK JUST
ENOUGH.
AND ROBERT THOMAS COMES RIGHT
IN THE MIDDLE, AND HE IS ABLE
TO LINE UP HIS SHOT PERFECTLY.
MATT DUCHENE GETS THE RSBERG, A-
TOUCH PASS.
DUCHENE IS BEHIND THE NET ON --
AND LOOK AT JOHANSSON -- JEN.
AND A SHOT IN THE SLOT, HOLM
GETS IT BACK, AND THEN FILIP
HIT EKHOLM, AND JOHANSSON.
I AM NOT SURE , EXACTLY.
THE
MOMENTUM.
HE GOETHE PUCK.
LOOSE IN
OUTLET PASS TO A WIDE-OPEN UNIT
BUT A GREAT PLAYMAKER THERE.
AND HUSSO GETS A PI SENDS KIND
RIGHT SIDE.
AND HERE COMES KERRY --  AND,
OKAY, HE ONE INTO THE WAS
PLAYED.
START TO FINISH, BATTLING BACK,
HE